am Wochenende am Frankfurter Flughafen
wieder demonstrieren Bauern wieder sind
rund 400 Traktoren auf der Straße wieder
demonstrieren sie gegen das Auslaufen
der Steuererstattung für Agrardiesel das
hat der Bundestag trotz wochenlanger
Proteste mit den Stimmen der Ampel am
vergangenen Freitag im Rahmen des
haushaltsfinanzierungsgesetzes
verabschiedet bislang bekommen Landwirte
21,48 Cent pro verbrauchten Liter
Dieselkraftstoff zurückerstatt
der entlastungssatz soll 2024 um 40%
sowie 2025 und 2026 um jeweils weitere
30% sinken und ganz
Auslaufen die SPD geführten Länder
Mecklenburg vorpommann Niedersachsen und
Saarland aber wollen längere
Übergangsfristen auf Betreiben der Union
wurde das
haushaltsfinanzierungsgesetz und damit
der Agrardiesel allerdings nicht am
vergangenen Freitag im Bundesrat beraten
das kann jetzt erst am am 22 März
geschehen dann könnte der Bundesrat
Einspruch einlegen und den
Vermittlungsausschuss anrufen der
Bauernverband gibt sich
kämpferisch jetzt muss mit der
gewonnenen Zeit sinnvoll umgegangen
werden und Lösungen im Sinne der
Landwirtschaft gefunden werden die
Steuererhöhung beim Agrardiesel muss vom
Tisch die Ampelkoalition versucht unter
anderem mit dem umstrittenen Abbau der
Subvention für Agrardiesel
Milliardenlöcher im Haushalt zu stopfen
die bauernproteste werden wohl vor erst
weitergehen und sprechen können wir
darüber mit dem Landwirtschaftsminister
jem östemir von Bündnis 90 die Grünen
schönen guten Morgen guten Morgen Frau
Meinhardt wir haben gerade eben gesehen
es gibt viel Kritik es gibt Kritik von
den Bauern aus der Union gibt es Kritik
und auch aus den SPD geführten Ländern
mecklenburg- vvorpommer Niedersachsen
und dem Saarland gibt es jetzt
Vorschläge den Abbau der
Agrarsubventionen doch noch etwas länger
zu strecken also noch mal was zu ändern
an an dem was bisher vorgeschlagen ist
ist das ein Kompromiss ein
möglicher das muss man mit dem Kanzler
mit dem Vizekanzler und dem
Finanzminister besprechen es muss ja im
Haushalt gegenfinanziert werden mein Job
war jetzt erstmal die Sparmaßnahmen im
ursprünglichen Umfang zu verhindern da
habe ich alles eingesetzt die KFZ
Steuerbefreiung ist wieder so wie sie
war und beim Diesel
nicht faceout auf ein Schlag so in drei
Schritten ob es jetzt weitere Schritte
gibt da bin ich falsche Ansprechpartner
den ich verhandel den Haushalt nicht das
machen jetzt die Spitzen der Koalition
mit im Bundesrat aber der Kritik der
Bauern und mit denen waren sie im
Gespräch die ist laut nach wie vor
lautstark und groß sie haben schon
angesprochen es geht um eine knappe
halbe Milliarde im Bundeshaushalt und
Scholz Harbeck und Lindner müssen dann
in Anführungszeichen überzeugt werden
wie groß sehen Sie denn die Chance sind
ja ihre Kabinettskollegen ich sehe vor
allem die Chance dass man den
Agrardiesel zum Anlass nimmt über all
die Themen zu reden die seit Jahr in der
Landwirtschaft liegen geblieben sind
wenn man mit Landwirten spricht dann
sagen die einem Agrardiesel ist
mittlerweile eigentlich ein Symbol
geworden für alles das was versprochen
aber nicht gehalten wurde unter früheren
Regierungen denken Sie die Umsetzung der
zukunftkommission Landwirtschaft die
Frau Merkel Mal eingesetzt hatte die
viele wichtige Empfehlungen gemacht hat
das was ich selber umsetzen kann setzt
sich ja um aber für viele Sachen brauche
ich entweder die Mehrheit in der
Koalition oder ein Bundesrat oder
Brüssel und da ist jetzt eine einmalige
Chance Zeitfenster hat sich aufgetan die
ganze Republik diskutiert Gott sei Dank
über die Themen der Landwirtschaft und
jetzt könnte man mit breiten Mehrheiten
diese Themen voranbringen dann lassen
Sie mich ganz kurz fragen sehen Sie denn
eine Chance dass sich da noch mal was
bewegt ganz kurze Antwort Ja oder Nein
ja es sehr vieles im Gespräch die
Finanzierung der Tierhaltung die
Stärkung der Bauer in der Lieferkette
die künftige gemeinsame Agrarpolitik all
die Themen stehen jetzt auf der
Tagesordnung ein Stichwort ist
Bürokratie Abbau das ist das was von
eigentlich allen Seiten ständig und
schon immer gefordert wird ist denn da
schon klar was kommt wir ja es gibt Gott
sei Dank jetzt endlich eine
Arbeitsgruppe zwischen den Ländern und
dem Bund die konkrete Ergebnisse
präsentieren soll ich hoffe dass die
Länder da auch mit guten Vorschlägen
kommen denn da liegt ein großer Teil was
Berichtspflichten angeht und der andere
große Teil liegt in Europa die nächste
gemeinsame Agrarpolitik die wird jetzt
vorbereitet ich finde man kann ein hohes
Niveau haben bei Umweltschutz Tierwohl
und trotzdem das bürokratieermer machen
da füre ich gerade Gespräche mit meinen
agrarministerkollegen in Frankreich in
anderen Ländern um auf Druck zu machen
dass die nächste gab bürokratieärmer
wird das heißt aber konkret können Sie
uns da noch nichts nennen dann schauen
wir auf den nächsten Punkt es ist bei
uns ein bisschen komplizierter wie in
Frankreich in Frankreich sagt der
Präsident so wird's gemacht er hat keine
Bundesländer wir haben 16 Bundesländer
und auch in Brüssel nochm ist es etwas
komplizierter weil drei
Koalitionsfraktionen müssen sich auf
eine Position in Brüssel einigen sie
kriegen ja mit dass es nicht immer so
reib klappt gehen wir zum Punkt Tierwohl
da schlagen Sie vor ein Tierwohl ent
einzuführen für Fleisch und Wurstwaren
wie genau soll denn das Aussehen auch
das ist nicht meine Idee s es ist eine
Idee aus der alten Legislaturperiode als
die CDU noch regiert hat da hat die
sogenannte beuchertkommission zum Umbau
der Tierhaltung benannt nach dem
ehemaligen Agrarminister noch unter
Zeiten von Helmut Kohl sehr angesehen
hat ein Vorschlag gemacht wenn man
möchte dass die Tiere mehr Platz
bekommen dass die tiergerechte gehalten
werden dann müssen die Stelle umgebaut
werden dafür Verschulden sie Bauern oft
müssen Darlehen aufnehmen mit 10 20
Jahren Millionen schwer das können sie
nicht finanzieren aus dem was sie zahlen
wenn sie Fleisch kaufen also braucht's
dafür eine Kompensation und der
Vorschlag der beucherkommission war z.B
dass man eine Abgabe macht oder eben
diesen tierwohlsind ja aber wenn sie
jetzt sich diesen Vorschlag auch
irgendwie zu eigen machen können Sie
vielleicht noch mal genauer sagen was
das genau in ihrer Meinung dann noch
sein soll ist das dann sind das dann 10
Cent pro Kilo oder
welche 40 Cent aufs Kilo vorgeschlagen
so viel brauche ich gar nicht weil die
beuchkommission ging davon aus dass man
alle Nutztierarten auf einmal umbaut das
mache ich ja nicht damit ich mit Brüssel
kein Problem bekomme s ich gehe
schrittweise vor beginnen bei der
Schweinehaltung da habe ich schon eine
Milliarde im Haushalt was ich jetzt
bräuchte sind viel geringere Summen 10
Cent würden maximal reichen um den Umbau
der Tierhaltung zu finanzieren das ist
umgerechnet auf Schnitzel oder auf den
dönner oder was auch immer Sie essen
wollen merken si es kaum aber es hilft
uns dass die
Tierhaltung so umgebaut wird dass sie
einerseits artgerechter wird und
andererseits die Bauern das Geld
bekommen für das was alle wollen in der
Gesellschaft alle umfragen sagen wir
sollen die Tierhaltung umbauen die
Bauern sind auch bereit dazu aber jemand
muss es halt auch finanzieren das heißt
also wenn Sozialverbände sagen Mensch
dann wird das Fleisch nicht mehr
bezahlbar für einkommensschwache
Haushalte da sagen sie das ist ein
Scheinargument nein das nehme ich
natürlich immer ernst aber ich glaube
nicht dass S an 20 € im Jahr oder sowas
entscheidet ich glaube das ist jetzt
nicht unser Problem in der Sozialpolitik
da muss man dann eher überlegen wie kann
man dafür sorgen dass gesundes Essen für
alle bezahlbar wird über die
außerhausverpflegung da sind wir ja auch
gerade dran also im Restaurant oder
beispielsweise wenn sie in der Kantine
sind wenn sie ihre Kinder in der Schule
essen in der in der Kita Essen das sind
glaube ich die Hebel wo der Staat helfen
kann sagt jem östemier von Bündnis 90
die Grünen Bundesminister für Ernährung
und Landwirtschaft vielen Dank dass sie
da waren szia Geni